The Greatest Practical Joke of the 19th Century
The year was 1809.
Famed English author, Theodore Hook, made
a bet with one of his close friends, the noted
architect and writer, Samuel Beazley, that
within one week, he could make any house in
London the most talked about place in the
city.
The house he ended up choosing was the home
of the widow Mrs. Tottenham on 54 Berners
Street, London, which was the same street
that Earl Stanhope and the Bishop of Carlisle
and of Chester, among other wealthy and well-to-do
individuals, lived on at that time.
It isn’t known why Hook chose Mrs. Tottenham’s
home as no connection between the two is known
and Hook himself never explained his selection.
It’s entirely possible that it just happened
to be a location where the home across the
street could be rented and was also in a fairly
well-to-do part of town which would help assure
Hook’s plan would work.
Whatever the case, the event began on November
27th.
Hook and Beazley positioned themselves in
the home across the street and around 5:00
am, the fun began.
First, a chimney sweep arrived.
The problem was that Mrs. Tottenham hadn’t
requested the services of a sweep.
Within a few minutes, 12 more sweeps arrived;
they too were also turned away.
Next, coal delivery workers began showing
up with several large carts packed with coal
to be delivered to Mrs. Tottenham; they were
turned away.
Following this, a cart-load of furniture arrived;
then workers showed up bearing a coffin for
Mrs. Tottenham.
Next came several cake makers attempting to
deliver very large custom made weddings cakes;
then several other chefs arrived attempting
to deliver a total of around 2,500 raspberry
tarts.
After that, several doctors, lawyers, gardeners,
fishmongers, dentists, grocers, priests, couch
makers, carpet-manufacturers, wig-makers,
coach-makers, curiosity dealers, opticians,
brewers, and shoemakers, among others, arrived.
They all came offering their services or bringing
very large orders of their wares that were
to be delivered to Mrs. Tottenham’s address
at various times throughout that day.
At one point, over one dozen pianos were delivered
to her door step.
After that, six men carrying a huge chamber
organ showed up.
Eventually the dignitaries arrived, including:
the Governor of the Bank of England; the Duke
of York; the Archbishop of Canterbury; the
Mayor of the London; the Lord Chief Justice;
several cabinet ministers; and the Chairman
of the East India Company.
Throughout the entire day, various parties
and delivery people crowded the area outside
of 54 Berners Street.
By mid-day, the streets in that area of London
became so crowded that the roads were jammed
for several blocks in every direction with
delivery people and on-lookers.
All the while, Hook and Beazley sat and watched
the chaos from across the street.
Hook’s part in the madness, that did indeed
become the talk of London, was not known until
much later when he eventually confessed it.
He did it all by sending around 4,000 letters
out to various entities in London, ordering
various items from the simple to outlandish.
He also wrote several notable individuals
like the Mayor of London and the like, creating
tales sufficient to get those people to come
and call on Mrs. Tottenham on that day.
What was written in most of the letters to
convince these people to come isn’t known.
One of the few that is known is the letter
to the Mayor of London.
Once he realized that everyone there was the
victim of an elaborate practical joke, he
went to the police station.
At the police station, the Mayor stated that
he had received a letter supposedly from Mrs.
Tottenham explaining that she was at death’s
door and she requested that the Mayor call
upon her home to bear witness to a deposition
she would give under oath.
After the hoax was revealed, the Mayor sent
officers out to attempt to instill some order
in the chaos in the streets, including attempting
to calm the crowds who were reportedly on
the brink of rioting with the streets jammed
with angry travelers and hundreds of merchants
who were infuriated that Mrs. Tottenham would
not pay for the often massive orders of their
wares they had come to deliver; some of these
products were also completely destroyed by
the crowds in the attempted delivery.
Along with the damaged goods, several fights
broke out throughout the day within the pressing
masses.
Once the crowds dissipated late in the evening,
Hook and Beazley emerged from the house across
the street and went home.
For successfully making the home the talk
of London within a week of the bet, Hook reportedly
received a guinea from Beazley.